benji is still seeing his shrink of
resume
but then he said to me well she's cute
and everything and i don't want to tell
her a bunch of things
i think he thinks he's going to seduce
her or something i don't know what he's
thinking but
if you're embarrassed to tell her stuff
then then maybe it's not there
what good is it yeah i i find myself
yeah
trying to dress a little nicer like wash
my face
he's on a date yeah he's on a date
you gotta be honest you should say
exactly that to her you're right but
it's
i wonder even if in a way it will make
me stronger to admit
all that to her i mean it's just
ridiculous that he's
wasting his money and not really getting
therapy
like benji what kind of stuff aren't you
telling her everything is
completely vague does she catch it does
she say you're not really being too deep
here dude
i don't know how long she's really done
this so
this is a total waste of time i think
it's not right
well i'll tell you what when a woman is
nice to me i feel good i'd be more
honest if you took your top off
how much does it cost it's great because
it's free
my insurance is completely paid up i can
do anything medical
till the end of the year and there's no
charge
i'm getting breast implants next
is she like always learning how to be a
therapist
is that what's going on if she hasn't
graduated she's like a few credits
like she's very close like she's not
like oh my god like that
veggies going to like therapists or us
what types of things are you uh talking
about in there
like i'm not happy with my life in lots
of ways and you know what would make it
different
if you if you were my girlfriend
you know benji i always dreamt of being
with a guy who had bigger tits than me
[Laughter]
when you're in therapy with this hot
chick do you wear that hat so she
doesn't know you're bald
yes benji why do you wear a hat
no therapy no no she's not asking
anything
she's not getting anything but rob don't
i look pretty good right now on camera
okay i'll give you that i know when i
look good i know when i look bad
right now i look cute and it's true
because he's far enough away from the
camera you can't see how blotchy
it is better closer i look better closer
let's see
like i do that sometimes the therapy
like when i really want you to do
it oh god help us
you would you ever [ __ ] benji robin
no like if you didn't know him like you
what you're looking at now you say is
attractive enough that you would
consider [ __ ] him
well if he wasn't talking right
i might entertain the idea wow all right
well that's a pretty good yeah that's a
pretty good mark
i can stay close you'll do whatever you
need
all right listen i had enough of all of
this great ending of the show yes
i think robin has been quarantined too
long
you're going very close to the camera
where you look your best
my meatball eyes are swooning here
you